this will be exists once upon a time
once upon a time please check also why
does any of this bull really need a
narration at this point movie makes up
Cinderella to see all sorts of magic and
all things but will totally forget about
this for the rest of the movie
with mr. goose and all the animal family
why is mr. goose the one animal that
gets a shout out in the narration
what about mr. goat back here or the
multiple mr. and mrs. Dickinson hurt the
other gays in this job what's so goddamn
special about mr. Guzy I see the remake
is live action but they retain the
cartoon mice
I believe that animals listen and speak
to us if we only have the ear for it
freezing your children to believe
animals could speak to you who looks
after us fairy godmothers of course no
doubt Cinderella will grow up to be a
future politician I believe in
everything even the Flying Spaghetti
Monster open ear the movie is an orgy of
evidence that this family is happy and
it's going to be sad when it's not they
knew themselves to be the most happier
families to live as they did and then
the narration spells out the happiness
after you just saw the happiness which
leads us to angriness this little
princess girl from olden times is going
to bed with a ton of obvious makeup
still on her face but sorrow can come to
any Kingdom no matter how happy how
happy are they
once again Cinderella's mom just plain
dies probably because of all the
happiness
courage but above all be blown pretty
Cinderella is played by someone named
Lilly James it was like Hollywood
pounded their fists on the table and
said bring me the next pretty face but
someone with Harry Potter's parents
names mashed together you'll call that
some time ago in my travels I made the
acquaintance of Sir Francis Tremaine
well I also got acquainted with his wife
if you know what I mean do you think I
may be allowed this genuine seeming
scenes of just the father is truly in
love again
but then the rest of the movie will only
show his evil stepmother with no trace
of any reason why daddy might have
originally fallen for animal cruelty
with matching cat leash also what kind
of sex power do you have when you make a
do forget how awful you and your two
daughters are and make them want to
marry you movie tries to show us how
evil this stepmother is by showing the
house full of drinking and gambling
I guess this form of happiness isn't
cool because it doesn't involve
butterflies and rainbows oh yeah this
still qualifies as an infestation mice
carry disease no matter how cute they
are glad to see the live action
adaptation kept all the crucial elements
of the original animated films plot
we ladies must help one another and then
someone had to work at a computer for
six months making sure we got this
Mouse's reaction and that's what I
really want you to come back she's
foreshadowing so hard I kind of wonder
if her dad might have lived if she'd had
just kept her piehole shut right here
stepmother comes out just in time to
overhear Ella's father talk about how
awesome Ella's mom was and how trying
the new family is miss huh do you know
what's why I married someone I mean
totally yeah I do
Anastasia and Drizella have always said
a rumor but why haven't you always been
rich but purpose did that serve other
than to make them a double-barrel
shotgun of offal I can stay in the Attic
look look directive was to have courage
and be kind now you're not being not
kind by objecting to this kind is not
mean be a doormat why build a house this
way hey guys got a great idea
let's build a six storey tower that
serves no purpose and then put an attic
at the top how did you even hear her
talking isn't she like several miles
upstairs I heard you subtle song
reference to the original film that is
wholly unnecessary and unmoving mornings
did not agree with Ella's stepsisters
maybe that's because they sleep in a
color explosion dee Antwoord fever dream
of a bedroom in fact they lacked
accomplishment in any heart you know
what would've been more interesting if
these sisters did have talent I think I
would have hated them even more it's
almost like throughout the centuries the
new retellings of this story didn't
cross the audience to hate people who
are clearly terrible why did you even
remake this movie you're doing almost
everything the same as the animated film
I hate this fucking cat also cat attack
of CGI mice shows why you can do these
things in an animated movie but in a
live action movie looks stupid
especially when you have to edit in such
a way that only implies the real cat
cartoon bumped his head into the
furniture he's passed on this her
stepmother and stepsisters ever misused
her almost 21 minutes of fluffy unneeded
backstory before this live-action remake
finally catches up to the original
cartoon story starting-point ruined you
know give the movie a little time and I
might be able to figure out how I feel
about these characters how can six bills
calling for service be ringing in a
household with only three human beings
besides Ella are you telling me the mice
and cat are ringing these other bells
and here is the most annoying roll
credits in history wouldn't you prefer
to eat when all the work is done Ella
or should I say Cinderella I think the
portrayal of the stepmother and the
stepsisters is made even worse by the
that just three months previous to this
into the woods rehashed all this to each
new medication tries to find ways to
make them more horrible than the last
one next Cinderella adaptation
stepmother and stepsisters send the mice
to the gallows and then make Cinderella
eat them Cinderella so distraught about
her slave-like conditions her step
family keeps her under she just has to
go for a horsey ride in the countryside
to clear her head I mean could you give
your downtrodden character anymore first
world outlets how is this ride even
happening Cinderella runs into Snape's
Petronas while riding on horseback ruby
decides to cast Game of Thrones Richard
Madden against type as a prince who
falls in love with the wrong woman
something tells me this won't end in a
red wedding but I'd knock off a hundred
sins if it did
we're circling conversation this what do
they call you who cares what they call
you how about what's your name so that
she doesn't have a stupid excuse not to
tell you he shouldn't be this deep in
the forest alone that's something only a
pervert would say wait is that Eva BISM
I see all the princes men decided to
forget about him long enough so that he
and Ella could have this conversation I
hope to see you again miss and I you
given the time period they basically
just had sex just counting the boob hey
I know let's have a scene where the
people are walking and talking but are
generally blocked by people in the
foreground
that's not frustrating to the audience
at all why do you say that when the
treats you mean she can believe anytime
she wants and the only reason she stays
to take the abuse is because of the
homestead which surely belongs to her
evil stepmother at this point anyway
legally speaking the prince shall choose
a bride also if you were riding around
the countryside yesterday and you wore a
blue dress and you talked me out of
killing a deer be sure to show up in
fact just come to the palace now it'll
save me lots of time and grief oh my god
I just realized she's a blonde Demi
Lovato captain wins his match against
KITT and somehow that's a cue for all
the other people who were in their own
individual matches to stop as well the
day of the ball arrived and the entire
kingdom held its breath in anticipation
maybe this is on purpose but this
narration and accompanying visuals feels
like they could be literally from any
fairy tale ever also this is where
despite my hatred for The Hobbit movies
I'm just dying to see smiled show up and
kill everything right now
this looked like Alice blond lead
actress and all the success of color
help me constantly checking IMDB to make
sure Tim Burton did not direct this when
myself in a cartoon its award-winning
ratatouille type when they help in a
live-action movie you jump the shark
before even getting in the water dog
stepsisters dressed for the ball like
1995 prom hookers I'd say no one in the
kingdom will outshine my daughters well
there are enough sparkly and reflective
surfaces on this dress to make that
statement my lack of the
every time I see this I wonder why
cinderella bothers what's the history of
the stepmother that has led her to
believe she's gonna get to go to the
ball just because she was economical in
making a dress
she should have just packed this thing
in a bag rode a horse to the palace and
changed somewhere out the woods or in an
outhouse or something luckily though a
fairy godmother designs to finally give
Cinderella some hope after long months
of abuse is too fragile
top of milk Cinderella does not wonder
why or how a sudden woman managed to
show up on the property without anyone
seeing her all so sudden a woman asks
for bread or milk and of course
Cinderella says yes because she's
kind-hearted my problem is that she only
has to walk five feet to find a table
with mass consumption milk on it I
thought this household was struggling to
keep up appearances and beeps milk and a
pitcher on the back patio after dinner
and long after leave for the ball time
is this the most convenient milk in the
history of film milk is better no what
was I
casting Helena bonham-carter does
nothing to remove the Tim Burton
overtones this film unintentionally
house oh did somebody say coach some
sort of strange magic code prevents the
fairy godmother from turning anything
she wants into a coach but we're
supposed to believe that a pumpkin could
be turned into one so I don't see why
there's a problem Disney in their
all-knowing wisdom realized a cutaway
establishing shot closed up on a couple
random lizards would thoroughly add to
your enjoyment of the film and so it was
done this will be a first for me
you mean existing you do what here
sure okay but how are we gonna get it
out of the green like I can care carry
on assholes or now stay with me you and
Cinderella both can lift the heavy
pumpkin outside and do it outside you
know the outside it turns out it was a
fantastic idea to create this pumpkin
carriage inside a closed structure movie
hilarity ensued of course I've just been
silently watching you suffer as a slave
the last couple of years because recents
sure lizards can become footmen but no
other object other than round fruit or
vegetables can become a coach literally
35 seconds of dress magic love can you
bring her back to life - we can - get
the body you'll be late for a very
important date
Oh God worlds are colliding here and I'm
losing are we sure Tim Burton had
nothing to do with this like absolutely
sure face floss I agree isn't that
dangerous as hell and you find that
really
because it's that cushiony kind of glass
the magic will only last so long and for
some reason I can't help you out with
midnight rolls around charging a fairy
godmother during medieval times requires
so many goat sacrifices midnight Thai
said the ancestor of Marty McFly
I'm sure Cinderella is having the time
of her life and this coach made from a
pumpkin a coachman made from a goose and
two footmen made of mice but couldn't
she also provided a violinist made from
a chicken so that she'd have some
entertainment on the way there
a princess it's a princess well nothing
how many princesses are there in these
here parts anyway huh if they're in such
abundant supply why have we only seen
one Prince and why are all the
princesses in the galaxy coming to this
marry the Prince ball Cinderella manages
to enter the palace and no one directs
her anywhere
so she somehow walks onto a balcony to
make a grand entrance so everyone can
see her and the film school 101 teacher
said you know how to make blue pop on
screen keep the rest of the shot as free
of blue as possible nudge wink remember
to thank me when you win the Oscar
despite the fact that no one knows
what's really going on
Cinderella's arrival was apparently so
amazing that everyone stops doing
whatever they were doing and
instinctively know to make way for her
as she walks to the floor it's you isn't
it well if you aren't sure maybe the
fairy godmothers magic is a little too
good skip who's that my mom she's
disguised worse than Clark Kent cometh
aunt you gotta love a culture where even
nervous lovers talk openly of their
emotions in front of expressionless
human guard statues this is where gossip
is born people and when the vain did my
portrait no they should ah whatever year
this is when this kind of line work I
already promised him in marriage to the
princess chelina we have no idea who
actually has the power to marry the
prince in this movie we see stellan
skarsgrd being all stellan skarsgrd
but how can he make the Prince marry
someone else we've been told the prince
can marry whomever he wants but we've
been told nothing concrete so what are
the rules you should I should skip these
two like each other and should be
granted time to explore that but I'm not
down with falling in true love in one
goddamn evening and that's just what
this movie is trying to pull
yeah did they just get late
is this a Freudian slipper where did you
tell me you really are so you I think
everything might be different you want
to see this guy again right we know that
eventually you have to tell him you're a
poor servant girl right I don't
understand what she expects to happen by
never telling him anything maybe we can
get married without him ever knowing my
name we're going in
my name is somehow the one dance they
had in the short walk through the palace
to the secret garden took five hours
also klaapa also 30 minutes from the
start of the closing credits and this
movie finally decides to toss in the
central conflict wait what the fuck
she's running back inside before running
back outside again youmu me this frog
was turned into a human for now even if
he craves flies his tongue is still
human right now you first also leftover
special effects budget was spent on this
bolt now for the most plot convenient
wardrobe malfunction of all fiction I
mean if she's this bad in heels that
should have fallen off ages ago
both of them glass slipper bounces on
stone and doesn't break somehow the
entire Kingsguard is alerted mounted and
on the chase before this carriage is
even gone a hundred yards I mean this is
gonna be the shortest search for the
glass slipper owner ever right the wait
at home is suddenly treacherous as if
the continental drift of Pangaea
occurred during the time she was at the
ball also why doesn't she just bail
obviously all is magically gonna run out
before you get clean away from the
prince so embarrassment or getting dirty
what's worse you know there are no seat
belts in this thing right why didn't you
plunge to her death yet all these
animals are changing back and at this
point out to ask can she survive at this
entire carriage goes back to normal at
top speed because I don't think she can
everything changes back one at a time
and definitely not in the order
everything was created also it was 11:59
when she started running out of the
palace and somehow she made it all the
way here before twill don't want oh look
at that she can survive if this thing
reverts to normal at full speed will
wonders never cease you'll find it
but for some reason this and the other
slipper didn't turn back into blue
slippers even though it was created by
that same magic with a midnight deadline
the mystery princess there are a lot of
unbelievable things I can accept in
Cinderella but these people not
recognizing her the ball is definitely
one I cannot the Prince is not free to
marry for love his promise to the
princess chelina of zaragosa
yeah but is that really a rule and even
if it is it comes way too late for me to
give it
mice really enjoy living and breathing
Cinderella's foot sweat
just what the story of Cinderella needed
but dying Prince's father drama
overbearing King dad turns out to have
pretty okay opinions after all on his
deathbed
also thanks dad for telling me this
earlier in the evening when I was
literally with an arm reach of the girl
I love how close his love the mysterious
princess knew King issues embarrassing
proclamation about his own lack of
ability to ID the girl he somehow
undyingly loved the ball he only cares
about the size of your feet not what you
obviously look like are you looking for
this Cinderella's stepmother just happen
to find her secret stash up in the act
because that's what lazy assholes do
walk up 80 flights of stairs to check
for secret panels hoping to find
evidence at the girl they couldn't even
recognize that the ball was in fact
their dirty servant of a stepdaughter
also dammit Cate Blanchet how does
Disney keep talking ain't Lister's into
appearing in these carbon copies
soulless live-action remakes I should
tell you a story once upon a time but
they even have once upon a time during
the age of once upon a time hope the
evil stepmother and cinderella forget
that the prince himself has the other
slipper to match this one so destroying
this one slipper does nothing to prevent
his search to find the girl who fits the
one he asked dumbasses why why because
you are young and innocent and good and
I cut myself off in the middle of Explo
at the time this long line of women
waiting to put on a slipper proved that
everyone's feet here are standard u.s.
units while Cinderella's feet are metric
I mean what a colossal waste of time
this is the Prince couldn't just get the
artist we saw earlier draw Cinderella
from memory and at least cancel out all
the Non Blondes oh yeah to put the
slipper on this woman would be
ridiculous movie what have me believe
Cinderella's house was the very last
house this army of slipper trekkers
bothered to slipper check again ladies
and gentleman comedy head I was third
her spirit was not broken she knew that
the ball at a time with the prince would
become beautiful disc
memories sickening isn't it Cinderella
sings in what many parts of the world is
called the ex machina song captain would
you be so kind as to investigate it
would be my pleasure
your majesty I will probably reduce all
the sins if they went through all this
trouble and the slipper somehow didn't
fit Cinderella then the prince even seen
her face and everything turned away and
said well I guess the search must go on
gents let's get on a ship to Braavos and
find this lady forthwith you haven't
never been and you never will be my
mother
haenam the whole reason why Cinderella
even got to this point is because she
continued to be courageous and kind like
her mother taught her now she's being
mean deservedly so it should have
happened long ago but she should pay for
her words if the movies theme is gonna
mean anything at all Cinderella doesn't
lock the door behind her as she leaves
have courage and be kind you know except
for when you need to give a
crowd-pleasing rebuke to your stepmother
one minute ago oh there you are don't
even need to ask any questions off we go
I have a Cinderella woman she just
accepts that insulting nickname her evil
stepsisters gave her and presents it as
a real name the prince may have found
his perfect fit but it will be ruined
after they have a kid yep she's the last
person he tried which means she
literally is the only person in this
entire huge-ass Kingdom with this shoe
size which is beyond not believable I
forgive you you easy to do that once the
new king is taking you out to marry him
isn't it they would have loved each
other wait who painted Cinderella's mom
and dad I've had to be from Cinderella's
memory right she didn't have existing
paintings of her parents did she no she
did not
so let me get this straight they met
twice had a nice dance and then met
again after he tried the loose shoe on
every woman in the kingdom found it fit
this peasant girl and voila the very
definition of true love
you would have a queen not care well if
you marry me
it's called a compromise it's just
called coercion as I far
she chopping back-alley
my brother laughs
Oh
Hale as old as time
true as it can be
you must suspect me to attack whatever
path naturally if I find it tip of
cancer side cap affair
and when the rain did my portrait no
they should I mean your boobs are huge I
mean I want to squeeze them hey you are
16 going on 17 baby it's time to if the
east and Juliet is the Sun who are you
I'm Batman who are you they call me mr.
Tibbs